la situation reste critique au royaume
uni le pays fait actuellement face à une
augmentation des contaminations attribué
à un variant plus contagieux une
accélération de plus en plus difficile à
contrôler et à londres
l'état d'urgence dans les hôpitaux a
même été déclaré vendredi dernier depuis
une semaine le gouvernement de boris
johnson a renforcé les restrictions
sanitaires
mais la responsabilité du premier
ministre est pointé du doigt par
l'opposition je pense que la grande
majorité du public s'est conformé aux
règles
ils ont travaillé très dur et ça a été
un vrai combat le problème ce sont les
messages contradictoires du gouvernement
manger au restaurant ne sortait pas
manger aller au travail ne retournez pas
au travail restait à la maison ne restez
pas à la maison
le message central est désormais d'une
importance cruciale restez à la maison
sauver des vies et protéger notre
système de santé
'l'annonce d'un troisième confinement a
du mal à passer outre manche
samedi plusieurs dizaines de personnes
se sont rassemblées à londres pour
protester contre le durcissement des
restrictions sanitaires
une manifestation dans un contexte tendu
qui s'est soldé par plusieurs
arrestations même conscient de la
situation sanitaire
les britanniques ont du mal à respecter
ces nouvelles restrictions en regardant
le parc je pense que les gens sont
fatigués d'être isolé ils en ont marre
d'être confiné entre quatre murs
c'est terrifiant je pense que nous avons
en quelque sorte atteint un point où
tout le monde doit prendre le virus
beaucoup plus au sérieux
[Musique]
mais ce troisième confinement est tout
simplement horrible et je pense que tout
le monde en a assez
nous voulons juste être prêt à trouver
une solution et attendre la fin pour
sortir de cette crise boris johnson mise
sur une vaccination à grande échelle qui
a commencé bien plus tôt que dans le
reste de l'europe
plusieurs vaccinodromes ont ouvert leurs
portes à travers tout le pays
le gouvernement espère avoir vacciné les
plus vulnérables et les soignants avant
la mi-février et le reste de la
population adulte d'ici à l'automne